37 % c'est le pourcentage des dépenses
qui doit être consacrée aux objectifs
environnementaux européen dans chaque
plan national de relance conditions a
priori sinéquanone pour avoir accès aux
aides de l'ue
les 27 avaient jusqu'au 30 avril pour
déposer leur copie à bruxelles
ce sont les fameux programme nommé plan
de relance et de résilience les pays
ont-ils respecter le critère
environnemental et quel impact les
mesures choisies dont elle avoir sur
notre planète c'est ce qu'ont cherché à
savoir trois think tank à travers la
création d'un outil le green recovery
tracker à ce jour ils ont épluché la
part des dépenses verte dans les plans
de relance de 15 pays
constat de nombreux états risquent de ne
pas remplir le critère des 37% de
nombreux plans de relance nationaux
risquent de ne pas atteindre l'objectif
de 37 % de dépenses verte
il existe des risques importants que des
mesures qui à première vue semble verte
finissent par soutenir les énergies
fossiles de nombreux plans incluent
encore des mesures non basée sur la
transition verte
la plupart des plans de relance ne sont
pas alignés sur le nouvel objectif
climatique de l'union européenne à
l'horizon 2030 et ne sont pas utilisés
pour accélérer la transition climatique
conformément au nouvel objectif
rappelons que cet objectif c'est la
réduction d'au moins 55% des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre de l'ue et par
rapport aux niveaux de 1990 ainsi que la
neutralité carbone en 2050 alors parmi
les mauvais élèves selon le green
recovery tracker on peut citer l'italie
alors que le gouvernement italien lui
évalue ses dépenses verte à hauteur de
40%
elle ne serait en réalité que de 16%
conséquence notamment d'une transition
énergétique peu soutenu selon les
analyses des think tanks
nous constatons un manque de soutien
approprié aux piliers cruciaux de la
transition énergétique notamment
l'expansion de la production d'énergie
renouvelable et l'utilisation directe de
l'électricité ainsi que les
infrastructures locales de mobilité
durable en bas de l'échelle on peut
aussi citer le portugal avec 17 %
consacrés à la relance verte ou encore
la pologne avec 18% du côté de la france
et
toujours selon l'analyse de green
recovery tracker la part de dépenses
vers du plan de relance français
atteindraient 23% si le think tank salue
un plan tourné vers l'avenir
il déplore le manque de contraintes
juridiques liés à l'application des
mesures
en tout seules deux pays remplirait pour
l'instant le critère des 37 %
l'allemagne et la finlande
tous ces plans de relance sont encore en
train d'être étudiées par la commission
européenne
ils devront aussi être validée par le
conseil européen
les versements des premières subventions
devraient intervenir durant le courant
de l'été
malgré le consensus affiché des états à
un vrai pour des économies plus vertes
les analyses du green recovery tracker
semble démontrer que la relance verte
est loin d'avoir été engagé